okay okay if your boy psych eval were
here we're gonna find dog collar right
oh boy kanye [ __ ] they put a [ __ ] the
chant Ralph it's [ __ ] [ __ ] did
they change it can I change it back
tough [ __ ] kind of gun is this is
[ __ ] okay otherwise let's do this oh
great anyway I'll see that [ __ ] drunk
stumbling
find me and we can talk okay watch out
for the villain inhabitants there if you
can blow them out or disintegrate them
thanks still alive how can I have this
sucks dick how's that it up that money
oh my god how can I he'll take this
money sad we're gonna waste that
something little want it i will check
speakers in reviews with the bomb call
the frequency and contributor detonated
mm-hmm this was scheduled me it is an
unfortunate side effect one I did not
anticipate I was unable to calibrate the
calmest to block the signals so you'll
have to make okay knew you would come
below the cage down to where I am maybe
you saw the ledgers I scratched on the
villa walls a little farther follow my
voice that's it the one dog I had to
lock him up he keeps disobeying me okay
that's me there on the table the disc my
voice can take any chances though you
may be some victim you simply stumbled
down here if so can't let you let dog
out if you're who I think you are you
came to fetch dog use him to drag others
here now I will use you and that pit boy
you're wearing your smart clever the key
to dogs cage is simple take my voice to
the cage above let me speak to the beast
inside okay how about like what am I
just like shot at him not [ __ ] that's to
get the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of me
okay that's [ __ ] horrifying
okay where the [ __ ] is they
okay and I do that play at the basement
Audio log
misc where the [ __ ] is it
No okay thank God what the [ __ ] how do i
play the basement Oh
dog back in the cage haga haga dog I
cannot carry here you warned who I was
expecting I'm disappointed ill I have
thought I reckon even if you aren't my
intended or perhaps you are with that
leashed I'm the voice of reason oh
that's the easiest i do you see the the
dog is the Beast it's close closer than
I'd like really they detach top no no
I'm not leaving until the one who
controls the collars shows and when he
comes just then I did
up
they would the old yep
Jesus on track and talking no I'm and I
put yes B dot you
No
hmm